maybe you guys can tell me maybe you
guys can help me with a new stand-up
joke that's not working okay okay ready
yeah this is i'm good at this you're
good at this yeah all right so i do a
bit you know my brave heart bit so the
braveheart bit is like the premise of it
is um
i wish one day hollywood would like
remake movies but put asian people in
white parts and in fact i want to remake
certain white movies braveheart i have a
joke about that right so i have a second
joke right what they should remake but
asian right so i go in north korea right
there's a lot of orphans
apparently on the streets and they get
hunted down sometimes and they get eaten
now the audience not money
yeah but the audience now is very
uncomfortable when i say that right then
i say that's why i want to remake the
movie north korean annie
right
kind of get struggle and then i go
what they made a black annie that kind
of gets a laugh right
and then i say um and i'm gonna it's
cheaper than the other andes because i'm
gonna save my money on casting there's
only one orphan andy the rest of them
are in a pot roast pot roast oh sweetie
it gets worse forget it it's a growner
keep going
what do you mean it's a grown right yeah
it's i don't really it just seems like
you're
i don't know do you have another joke
that i'm not done with the joke okay can
i feel
all right so i'm going to cast kim
jong-il okay as daddy how are you going
to get him
if that's a heckler
oh yeah that's a heck of a heckler
that's a heckler and that's what my
response is when i get heckled what i
just did but just just
just just which makes me yeah i mean not
that great of a comeback guy
right well let's work on that one
all right so why don't we do this right
yeah yeah all right so here we go so i'm
gonna you know me and cast kim jong-il
i'll play a heckler okay
already assumed
that's already a suit that was
established
you're wearing a mustache right
all right so um i'm gonna cast kim
jong-il where's
hey man where's [ __ ]
mr magoo okay all right i'm sorry
i just got him got him i got him got him
got him did i get him yeah yeah all
right so hey i'm sorry no i'm sorry yeah
i'm gonna cause kim jong-il as um daddy
war [ __ ] that's what i call them okay
thank you one laugh
i'm already never gonna tell this joke
again yeah yes so then i go um
but don't worry about it right i'm gonna
keep the music the same just change the
lyrics a little do you have grey goose
okay you gotta griggers and cranberry
imagine a wide shot on annie right
it's a heart a life just for me
right belvedere and then daddy war fox
jumped into frame and got something with
cranberry it's about to get hotter
right then he picks up annie tilts his
head back and eats her hole like a snack
a sneak-eating hamster
spin the
credits rule down and he's still
chomping away at eddie i've been telling
this joke for the last three weeks i
can't get a lava
and scene
that's what you've been writing in your
little joke
yeah yeah you know what i hate i hate
the fact that it didn't do well i'm
gonna i'm not gonna give up on it don't
give up i'm not gonna give up there's
something there you know i've learned
you don't for me at least don't um
don't try your jokes
anywhere but on stage because it doesn't
work you're right you're absolutely
right
okay you're the boss
i was just agreeing
well you were you were cutting me off
for telling you my reasons why
please continue
you know i i i wasn't feeling like i had
it today yeah but um do you feel it
well
yeah yeah i feel it's it's what it's
supposed to be i feel this is what's
supposed to be yeah